Nobody is safe in the world of The
Walking Dead — and even whole scenes
can be devoured alive. Here's the
ending you'll never get to see.
After 11 seasons, The Walking Dead is finally
resting in peace. The ending the program gave
loyal viewers was nothing if not bittersweet:
While the majority of its regulars survive,
Rosita Espinosa, Luke, and Jules all succumb
to walker bites. But the rest of the cast of
characters thrive and find family, happiness,
and romance. Their settlements grow in peace as
well. The show's three upcoming spin-offs are
set up, too, with Daryl Dixon choosing to roam
the country protecting others, Negan taking off
for New York City, and Rick Grimes and Michonne
both seen fighting for their lives miles apart
in completely different locations. Meanwhile,
Judith Grimes and her half-brother, RJ, continue
to wait at Hilltop for their parents' arrival.
"You deserve a happy ending, too."
"I'll be back."
While this was an ending that
moved many in the show's audience,
it turns out that the series had planned an
entirely different conclusion to the adventures
of our intrepid survivors. This ending inspires
hope for the future in a completely different
way from the aired version and cements the
survival of several Walking Dead characters.
Per an article published by Insider, The Walking
Dead was initially slated to end with a peek into
the future. Greg Nicotero, an executive producer
and director of the series, revealed during a
Zoom call that the series finale we saw was not
necessarily the planned series finale. He said:
Insider proceeded to confirm this deleted
scene through two members of the show's crew,
who preferred to remain anonymous.
According to them, the final scene
would have taken us back to Atlanta,
Georgia — specifically, Freedom Parkway,
down which Rick Grimes rode on horseback
during the show's first episode. But this time,
the characters traveling down the highway are
in a van. The scene would be shot in such a
manner as to reveal that these characters are
now-grown Judith, RJ, and their friends. They are,
just like their parents, apparently on a mission
to rescue others from the apocalyptic battlefront
and reunify disenfranchised communities. It's
hinted that some progress has continued to be
made technologically as well, as the van
apparently runs on ethanol. This grown-up
version of RJ speaks into a longwave radio,
calling out for any survivors. The episode,
and the show, was to end with an unseen
survivor speaking back through the radio.
So why didn't AMC end The Walking Dead
somewhere in the far-flung future? The
crew members Insider spoke to gave reasons
that mesh with Nicotero's — it simply didn't
serve the franchise's future health.
While one crew member said that ending
the show with new versions of characters
we weren't invested in didn't make sense,
another mentioned that the original ending
was simply more fitting, emotionally-speaking
This all stems from the fact that the comic
book version of The Walking Dead also ends
with a 25-year time jump. The focus of that
final issue is Carl Grimes, who, of course,
did not survive until the show's end in
the television universe. While neither
version places a neat bow on the show and
leaves things open for further sequels,
it's understandable why AMC felt the need
to establish Rick and Michonne's upcoming
sequel. Still, it's hard not to be
curious about what could have been.